[Music]
so george i got to get you to weigh in
okay on something i saw in the news i
don't weigh much but i'll try it
well
it's well played sir okay so here's the
headline i believe this is wall street
journal yeah
uh
millennials
team up
to fulfill the dream of home ownership
burdened by debt and facing soaring home
prices first time home buyers are
pooling their finances with partners
friends or roommates
what
george this is frightening say it isn't
so it is so wall street journal is
pretty reputable yeah here's the thing
it says the number of co-buyers with
different last names increased by
771 percent between 2014 and 2021. so
this isn't just a 2021 phenomenon
and what's happening is uh millennials
are strapped with student loan payments
and all kinds of other payments and they
can't afford home ownership and they're
going to inflation and i live in a high
cost of living area and so what do you
do ken you call up your buddy and say
hey rent is real expensive what if we
went in on this and we became homeowners
together okay now let's talk about the
nuances there
it's not a it's not a a spousal
situation where you both have the same
last name no and as we teach shared
assets and all that stuff shared bank
accounts these are two completely
different individuals so uh two of my
favorite fake names to use in these
scenarios is bob and larry so let's say
sandwich by the way would do this no
millennials on the planet are named bob
and larry parents don't name their kids
that anymore they don't maybe robert
okay so let's go with
let's go with robert and uh
randolph perfect and robert and randolph
are buddies and they go okay well let's
go do this and so they buy a house
together
what's that look like they're both on
the loan
yes it's called the joint tenancy or
tenancy in common okay and so it's it
happens and it's just two buddies
friends they don't have any marital no a
connection and they just want to own a
home and so you can you legally it's
possible it's not an illegal thing to do
it's totally fine to do but it's a very
dangerous move why is it dangerous well
um homeownership is a big deal yeah and
when you got your name
on the title of that home uh and then
you gotta go okay who's going to hire
the handyman who's going to handle the
mortgage payments uh what if one moves
away what if one gets married and so
what happens is uh there can be a lot of
hairy stuff in that relationship that
goes down yeah i mean you're stuck i
said well robert robert meets a gal
falls i want her to move in you're
getting moved out wait wait wait wait
wait house too i co-own the house it's
just an and by the way we're at the very
top of the onion here we haven't really
peeled it there's all kinds of problems
here legal mess
uh relationship mess i mean it's just a
mess but like many things it looks good
on paper and you go well financially
this is a great move when it comes down
to the numbers but when people see this
through these rose-colored glasses and
then life happens
it gets real messy and i think we're
going to see a lot of relationships hurt
by this as we try to figure out all the
nuances of homeownership with someone
that you don't have a real connection
with so
the moral of the story is please don't
fall prey to this supposed good idea
this has just got all kinds of crazy
risk attached to it but i mean wow
extreme times it points back to
what we're trying to do with this
borrowed future documentary help people
get rid of their student loans so that
they can live the american dream yeah
buy your own house
yeah i love it home ownership